in Sri Lanka fire dancing reigns supreme
dozens of troops spin literal rings of
fire lighting of parades and
celebrations all around the country
Lana thorny me ended up the Chris a
longer and longer and a lot burned a
definite McGee nama sameas over vida
we know the circus among Guinea borders
and Lankan models in Lanka Sumida is
part of a fire dancing troupe of about
25 members spread across the country a
pagan no no adult in me single beautiful
there are again Lee the dick and Alina
piadina piranha gonna get Lumumba
Tallulah dog in part two we're gonna go
take a castle on Davina and we have time
again Ebola yet piranha Sri Lanka rowdy
the effectiveness of belonging in need
not Kerala Melissa we need an aggregate
by an irregular among any diminution
monkey in Ebola forgot the departing
Barak Valley tomorrow Alateen no the
practice Athena no mo patina Barnett
despite the danger scimitar loves what
he does
okay nibble Aharon osawa Tino Monte
Verde atomic are gonna in the double our
team
Oh Guinea bola a pig away put your tiara
passivity know what you got till no in
the townhome I got three opposed to gun
do not think I will do a lot it's not
your honor
[Music]